The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: OK,
so let me remind
you of what we were
talking about last time.
So we were discussing
the example of DIS
in the Breit frame.
And the way we led
into this example
is we talked about
renormalization group evolution
with a heavy light current.
And we saw that it had
this [INAUDIBLE] dimension.
But it was a multiplicative
renormalization group
evolution, and I said that
that happened because we only
had one collinear
gauge-invariant
object in our operator.
And then I just wrote down an
operator that looked like this,
and I said, there's
one that has two.
If we run that object, we will
get a renormalization group
equation that
involves convolutions.
And I said that that's
going to give you
the renormalization group
evolution of a parton
distribution function.
And we wanted to explore that.
And so in order to
explore that, we
should think of
some process that
has the parton
distribution function in it
so we can really
make sure we know
precisely what the operator is.
And that process is DIS.
That's the simplest process.
So we started thinking about
deep inelastic scattering
in the Breit frame, which
is this framework, Q,
of the photon.
It has that form, just a
component in the z-direction.
And in that frame,
the incoming quarks
in the proton, quarks and
gluons, are collinear.
Intermediate state,
the outstate,
the x-state that's
going out, is hard.
So you can think
of a-- if you were
to draw perturbative diagrams,
you'd draw them like this.
And this propagator
would be hard.
It would have a hard momentum.
And then you would
have loop corrections
that could also be hard.
In the effective
theory, you don't really
have to think about
what diagrams.
You just write down the lowest
possible dimension operator,
and everything that's
a loop that's hard
goes to the x,
which is the Wilson
coefficient, if you like.
And likewise, we also get
not just external quarks,
but external gluons
from diagrams.
In the full theory, it would
involve a quark loop like that.
OK, so this is going to
lead to the quark PDF,
and this is going to
lead to the gluon PDF.
And we decided we would do
the quark one in some detail.
So this is kind of writing
out now the operator
and the Wilson coefficient in
kind of a combined notation
where this w plus and minus
are w1 plus and minus w2.
And then we had
one more formula,
which is where we ended.
So we have a collinear proton,
and then we have this operator.
And then we have the
collinear proton again.
And this matrix element
can be written as follows.
So this is the last
formula we had last time.
So some things here
are just conventions,
but other things are important.
Well, everything's
important, but some things
are more important
than other things.
So this quark here has a flavor.
It could be an up quark.
It could be down quark.
Let me denote that
by an index i.
This proton here is collinear.
And really, all that
matters for this example
is that we have some--
we can think of it as a
massless proton, even.
And as far as its
momentum is concerned,
we can think of it as massless.
So really, the only momentum
that matters in here
is the minus momentum--
so minus, which is n bar dot
P, and that's what this is--
n bar dot P, n bar
dot P. It's capital P.
So capital P was
the proton momentum.
And we can think of this state
as just carrying large P minus.
All the other components don't
matter for this matrix element.
But it's a forward
matrix element,
so both states carry
the same large momentum.
And that's what led
to this delta function
here that says that w1 and
w2, with the sign conventions
we have, this guy has the
opposite sign convention.
And so if it's
forward, these two guys
have to have equal momentum
so that the sum is 0.
And if you take into
account the sign,
then that means w minus is 0.
So that's what that
delta function is doing.
And then the sum is something
that's not constrained
by the matrix element.
And so the sum could either
be positive or negative.
If it's positive,
we can say that it's
some fraction of
the proton momentum
because this is a
quark inside the proton
and it carries some
momentum, but it
can't be more than the proton.
Otherwise, we would get 0.
So it's some fraction,
and that fraction
is defined to be
xi in this formula.
And the reason there's
a 2 is because I'm
adding the w1 and the
w2, which are equal.
So this is the
momentum fraction.
And then we can have
an arbitrary function
of that momentum fraction.
Nothing stops us from
writing that down.
And that's kind of
where we got to.
Now, so on general
grounds, you can
argue that that's the
most general thing
that you can write down
for this matrix element.
And I tried to argue
about why that's true.
From charge conjugation, you
can actually do something more.
So you can let charge
conjugation act
on these operators.
And since charge conjugation's
a good symmetry of QCD,
you can prove that
that relates, actually,
the quark and antiquark
operators in the following way.
So quark and antiquark operators
are switching signs of w plus--
so if I switch
the sign of w plus
that's going from
quark to antiquark.
And basically what happens
in the operator when
you do charge
conjugation, remember
that [? chi ?] goes over
here to [? chi ?] transpose
and the w switches sign.
So basically, what charge
conjugation is doing
is taking w1 to minus
w2 and w2 to minus w1.
And that's why the w plus,
which is signed by the w minus,
doesn't.
And then there's an overall
sign just from the fields--
so from the usual
charge conjugation
transformation of the
fields for a vector current.
OK, so these are all orders
of relation between the Wilson
coefficients.
So really, when you
do the matching,
you really only need to do
the matching for the quarks.
So if you want to do the
matching calculation,
you'd do a matching calculation
for the Wilson coefficient
with positive w plus.
And you could do it for
the antiquarks, as well,
but you would just be
basically wasting time.
Now, last time, we went through
the kinematics of the Breit
frame a little bit.
And this n bar dot proton
momentum is actually Q over x.
So we could also write
this formula like that.
And so you see that
w plus is actually
something that's [? xi ?]
over x, Bjorken x, which is
an external leptonic variable.
Now, there was another
index over here, j, which
we talked about last time.
And that had to do with
the fact that we're
taking the forward scattering
graphs with a tensor
and we decompose that
into two scalars,
multiplying things
that had indices.
So there were two
possible things
that we could write down.
And the index j is
just this 1 or 2.
And there was a
similar decomposition.
In the effective theory, we
could think of decomposing--
the effective theory
is a scalar in terms
of the scalar
operators, which are
these guys, with some
coefficients that
have some indices, then
multiplied by some tensor.
So these guys
don't have indices,
but I could just multiply
them by effectively
the effective theory
versions of these tensors.
And so that that's
why there's a j here.
Is that clear to everybody?
OK, so there's various
indices-- i flavor,
j for tensor decomposition,
and then a bunch
of momentum indices.
So when you go
through the analysis
of trying to find a
formula for, say, T1,
it's going to be related to C1.
And T2 will be
related to C2, OK?
Because this guy's
a scalar operator.
It doesn't have any indices.
So the way that that works, if
you just look at the two bases
and write down the formula,
you'd have an integral over
these w's.
There are some prefactors
which just come about
from being careful,
and then the thing that
has an imaginary part of
these Wilson coefficients,
and then you have
matrix elements
of operators, which
have a flavor index
but don't have a subscript j.
So in general, this
has a flavor index.
Keep track of things.
And then there's
another one for T2--
so kinematic prefactors that
are easy to work out that
just come about from
the fact that we
wrote the tensors and
the effective theory
and the full theory
slightly differently.
But these two guys have
the same matrix elements
of the same operator.
And all the sort of
tensor stuff is just
saying that there's two
different Wilson coefficients
that you have to
compute, and that's
because you have these vector
currents from the photons.
OK, so this is what we're after.
These show up in
the cross-section.
And what we're doing is we're
writing, at lowest order,
the things that show up in
the cross-section in terms
of effective theory objects,
the Wilson coefficients and then
the matrix elements
of our operators
here, which is this
thing in square brackets.
And we're almost at what you
would call a factorization
theorem.
Factorization theorem is a
result for the cross-section,
in our language, in terms of
effective theory quantities,
and that's going to factor
the hard stuff, which
is the pink stuff, which is
in these Wilson coefficients,
from the low-energy stuff,
which is in these operators.
AUDIENCE: So those pink elements
are [INAUDIBLE] equation.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And what is
square bracket [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: It's both.
AUDIENCE: It's both, OK.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I can write it like
this, if you like.
Any other questions?
OK, so literally what I
do is I take this formula
and I plug it into that formula.
And when I do that, I can do
one of the integrals trivially
because it's a delta function.
This one's just trivial.
And then I do this one with
the other delta function.
So both integrals
are actually trivial.
And I can write the result
in terms of something
that I'll call the
hard function, which
is just the imaginary part
of the Wilson coefficient.
And I'm going to denote
it in the following way.
So this is w--
the Wilson cost
efficient can depend
on various different things.
It can depend on w plus.
It can depend on w minus.
It can depend on the hard
scale, which is q squared.
Or it could depend
on mu squared.
So w minus, when you do the
delta function, gets set to 0.
w plus gets set to something.
And it's convenient
because of the way
this delta function is with
the-- it kind of has a ratio.
Because this function
is a function of xi
which is the ratio
of two things,
it's convenient to
define a dimensionless z
and only talk about a function
of that dimensionless thing.
And if you do that, then the
final result for these kind
of T's, which are
imaginary parts of T's--
you can just put the
formula together.
I'll write one of them--
is that.
And then there's a
similar formula for in T2
that involves H2 and H1.
OK, so this is the
factorization theorem.
And it came about, in some
sense, just trivially.
Once we knew how to
write down the operators
in the effective theory,
we were basically done,
and then the rest was just sort
of algebraic manipulations,
being careful about
what momenta go where,
and knowing what the sign of
this formula for the matrix
element is.
This is a kind of
important point.
But in some sense, the effective
theory, from the get-go,
was already designed
to factorize
because we were integrating
out the hard degrees of freedom
right at the start.
And so knowing what operators
and knowing their matrix
element is really all we
needed to do to get to the DIS
factorization theorem.
So if you ever look
up the original way
that this was derived,
it was not that easy.
This is actually
something that's
very complicated in a sort
of traditional approach.
But in the effective
theory approach,
it becomes almost trivial.
And this is an all-orders
result because we never
expanded in alpha s.
We just used symmetries,
and we used the fact
that we knew what form
the operators would
take when we integrated out
the hard degrees of freedom.
So any alpha s corrections
that one might want to add
will fit into this formula.
And this gives a perturbative
result for this H,
which you would compute in
perturbation theory, which
people do [INAUDIBLE]
these days.
Now, if you ask
about things like--
I didn't write
all the possible--
I suppressed some things, right,
like Q squared and mu squared.
If you ask about the Q
squared and the mu squared,
then your Wilson coefficients
do depend on Q squared
and mu squared.
And the Wilson
coefficients, H here,
are actually dimension--
the Wilson coefficients,
the original one, [? xi, ?]
were dimensionless.
So the H is dimensionless.
I just pulled out the
dimensionable factor
so that that would be true.
And so this guy can depend
on Q squared over mu squared.
The fact that Q squared
only shows up there,
that's Bjorken scaling.
And if you look at the
perturbative result for T2,
then it vanishes
at lowest order.
And so that's the
Callan-Gross relation.
So there's various things
that are sort of encoded
in this that come out, from the
effective theory point of view,
in a very simple way.
OK, so let me write.
So there's logarithmic
corrections
that involve Q in the
Wilson coefficients
that will show up like that.
So there's a mu also that you
could add to this formula.
So the way that I
described it, we
didn't think too hard about
bare versus normalized, right?
We just take these operators.
So far, they could
have been bare.
But remember that when you have
C bare, O bare in [INAUDIBLE]
Hamiltonian, for example,
that's C mu, O mu.
So switching from bare
and renormalized--
I mean bare operators
and coefficients
to renormalized operators
is simply a matter of
sticking in a mu here,
and then you imagine
that the renormalization
has taking place.
So we could equally well
insert in these formulas
a mu for that.
And then what I'm saying is that
there being logs of mu over Q
will make a little more sense.
So there's also a Q. Squeeze
everything in here [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, now we're being
completely honest
about what it depends on.
All right.
So traditionally what happens
in the traditional literature,
people talk about factorization
scales and renormalization
group scales.
So factorization
scales is the fact
that this parton distribution
function is mu-dependent-- so
operator that you
have to renormalize,
and we're going to
do that in a minute.
And so there has to
be a cancellation.
Since this thing here
is a physical observable
and is independent
of mu, there has
to be a cancellation of
the mu-dependence here
and the mu-dependence
here, all right?
And that's this mu.
So the thing that's
multiplying this result here
would involve a cancellation
of mu-dependence
here and mu-dependence here.
So the same anomalous
dimension would show up
in both the H and the f.
And then sometimes people
also talk about mu-dependence
that's just cancelling
within H itself.
And they call that
renormalization group
renormalization group mu.
Sometimes people vary
these independently.
In the effective theory,
it's really simple.
You really just have
the classic setup of you
have some hard
degrees of freedom.
In this case, you can even
think of it one-dimensional.
You have some hard
degrees of freedom
that you want to integrate out.
You have some scale
which we could
call mu 0 that's
of order 2 where
we do that integrating out.
And then you can run
down or you could
run in a more complicated way.
So you could run the PDFs
which are sitting here
at the collinear scale,
which is lambda QCD.
You could think of evolving
them up to some scale
and evolving the Wilson
coefficients down and meeting
somewhere, OK?
And so, yeah, it's just really
a sort of classic running
and matching picture.
Here, I've just
used the fact that I
could run either one of them
or I could run both of them
to a common scale.
So I usually would pick mu
to be either something small
or something large rather
than running both things.
But in general, you could think
about running both things.
And we've talked about
having anomalous dimensions
for either one of these.
And usually, we just
run one of them, OK?
But it's no more complicated
than the standard picture
of integrating out modes and
doing renormalization group
evolution.
So if we want to do tree-level
matching or one-loop matching
or any kind of matching--
let me just show you
tree-level matching.
So tree-level
matching, you would
compute this forward
scattering graph,
and that will give you the
other diagram that we drew.
And so you'd want to match
this guy onto that guy.
And what you find is you
find one tensor structure
at lowest order.
So C1 is not equal to 0.
C2 is equal to 0.
And that's the
Callan-Gross relation
which tells you about
the spin of the object
that you're scattering
off, and this
is how we know that quarks are
spin 1/2, or one way we know.
And then you can calculate
C. And so that way
that I set things
up, C was complex,
and then I had to take
the imaginary part.
So C is just this
propagator, basically.
And it's only a nontrivial
function of w plus.
There are some charges
that sit out front.
And so the only way
that this guy depends on
whether it's an up
quark or a down quark
is you have 2/3
squared or 1/3 squared.
And then there's something that
comes about from the propagator
that looks like this.
And then I take
the imaginary part
and then I get H1, which
is a function of z, which
is the xi over x.
So if I write it as xi
over x like it shows up
in the factorization
theorem, then I'm
getting a delta
function of xi over x,
which is this coming from this.
So the lowest-order H1
is just a delta function.
And that's where the
parton model picture
comes from because
the parton model
picture is that you think of xi
and x as being the same thing.
And that's the tree-level
way of thinking,
and that's just satisfying
this delta function
and the hard function.
And then you would
get that the T is just
given by the parton
distribution at x, which is
the external measurable thing.
OK?
So this is how all these
classic things come about
in the effective
theory language.
Any questions about that?
All right, so let's
renormalize this operator
and see how the classic result
for the renormalization group
evolution of a PDF comes about.
And again, the way that
you should think about this
is you have an operator, and
you should just renormalize it.
And once you've got
the effective theory,
you shouldn't have to think too
deeply about what you're doing.
You should just be able
to follow your nose
and do the renormalization.
You may have to be careful
because these operators are
kind of complicated.
They have this
dependence on these w's
that you have to
be careful about.
But really, it's just
follow your nose,
compute the one-loop graphs.
If you look up how Peskin would
do one-loop renormalization,
there'd be an infinite
number of operators
you'd have to derive in a
renormalization group, result
for all of them.
Here, we only have one
operator and we're just
going to renormalize it.
Our operator is
nonlocal in the sense
that it depends on
these omegas, and that's
what's encoding this
infinite number of operators
that Peskin has.
OK, so solving, if you
like, for f from the formula
that we had before,
I can do that
by integrating over the w minus.
That sets these
guys to be equal.
And then if I--
so I can think of it as that
there's one free momentum, xi.
And that free momentum xi
is one of these labels,
which is this guy here.
So xi is w over
Pn minus, and this
is the proton which is carrying
some momentum Pn minus.
This is the proton state, which
carries momentum Pn minus.
And there's one delta function.
I could put it either
place, but I only
need one because the other
one's kind of trivial.
So the first thing you
can think about doing here
is looking at mass dimensions.
And I already told you that
this guy was dimensionless,
but let's check
that that's true--
so a mass dimension.
So relativistically
normalized states
have mass dimension minus 1.
Quark fields that don't
have a delta function
have mass dimension 3/2.
The delta function gives a
minus 1, and then a minus 1,
so you get 0.
3/2 plus 3/2 minus 3/1 is 0.
So that means this f is a
really dimensionless function,
and that's why it makes sense
that we defined it to depend
on this dimensionless ratio.
You can also look at
the lambda dimension,
and here's how that works.
That's also 0.
So the only thing that's-- so
we already had power counting
for our kai fields.
Remember, the c field
inside the chi field scale
like [? 1. ?] So this is just
coming about because this guy's
order lambda.
The delta function just
involves large momentum,
so it has no power counting.
And the only thing
that's nontrivial
is that the states have
power counting minus 1.
So here's how we
can derive that.
So if you think about
relativistically normalized
states, what you're
doing is you're
defining sort of the
inverse of this d3 p
over e, which you
can write actually,
which is more convenient
for power counting,
in terms of things that we
can power count more simply.
So this is an exact relation
for a nontrivial particle
between p minuses and pz.
So then I can write,
because of that,
the standard relativistic
normalization
formula for a state with
two different momenta
as kind of the inverse,
which would be this.
So the usual formula would have
2e and then delta 3, right?
Because it's the
inverse of this.
But I can write
it also this way.
This guy is lambda 0.
This guy is lambda minus 2.
Therefore, each of these
guys must be lambda minus 1.
That's where the
minus 1 came from.
All right, so we want to
renormalize that thing,
that matrix element.
And what loops can do is
that they can change omega.
So you might-- or xi,
which are equivalent.
And so the way that you
should think of that
is in the following
sense, and it's actually
something you're familiar
with, although you're
familiar with it for
discrete quantum numbers.
And here, in some sense,
we have a continuous one.
So you have some
function, fq, that
depends on some variable xi.
And it can mix, under the
renormalization group,
with an operator at a
different value of xi.
So you can really
think of the fact
that loops can change this
omega as just a mixing.
You're used to mixing for
discrete quantum numbers.
You write down all the operators
that have the same quantum
numbers, and they can mix
under renormalization.
Here, there's kind of
an additional thing
that the object can depend
on, which is the xi parameter.
And in general, when you
do the renormalization,
that can change too.
Because the operators
or matrix elements here
are labeled by this
xi, in general, there's
no reason that it should
stay the same under the loop
corrections.
And it was really a special case
that we dealt with last time
where that did happen.
But in general, it doesn't.
OK, so this is
actually what we expect
to happen in general unless
we can argue that it doesn't
happen because you should
think of each value of xi
as giving a different operator
or different matrix element.
So I could write formulas
here just for the operator.
It's actually the operator
that gets renormalized,
not the matrix element.
So I'm going to keep
writing f's just
to avoid too much notation,
but we could always actually
replace the f's by
just the operator.
And we could do everything
in terms of actually
just the w instead
of the xi variable.
But I'll just keep using f.
So what does this mean
in terms of the operator
is the following.
We can think of, if we
have some bare operator
and we want to split that into
a piece that has divergences
and a piece that is
just the finite pieces,
the general formula for doing
that involves an integral.
So this guy here--
so there's also these
indices, i and j,
and that's the flavor, if you
like, or quarks and gluons.
So i is quark or gluon.
And in general, you can also
have a mixing in the quark
and gluon operators.
We started with these
two different operators,
and they can mix under
renormalization as well.
So there's two operators in the
effective theory, same order
in lambda, and they can mix
when you do the renormalization.
And I'll draw a
diagram in a minute.
So this thing here
is mu-independent.
This thing here in MS bar has
all the 1 over epsilon UV's.
And it also depends
on alpha of mu,
and it depends on
these xi and xi prime.
And this guy here is UV-finite.
So this guy here is
really the thing that's
the low-energy matrix element.
But remember what low
energy meant here.
Low energy was physics
at lambda QCD, physics
of the initial-state proton.
So actually, in this guy,
there are IR divergences.
This is just some matrix
element in the effective theory,
and in general, it
could be IR-divergent
if you calculate it.
And this guy actually is.
And it really encodes--
that's not going to bother us
at all because this is really
some universal thing that
encodes lambda QCD effects,
and that's what parton
distribution functions are.
Then from the point of
view of what we're doing,
it doesn't really matter that
it has this extra IR divergence
so that we will have
to regulate diagrams
in order to separate UV and IR
divergences because of that.
Really, in terms of
the renormalization,
what we're after is
getting the UV divergences.
OK, so the usual kind
of formula that you'd
have where you just
write o is z times o
is slightly more
complicated here.
There's this extra integral.
And now, remember how you
derive a renormalization group
equation.
What you do is you say mu
d by u mu is this guy is 0.
And so if I take mu d by d
mu, on the right-hand side,
I get mu d by d mu of z
and mu d by d mu of f.
And I can rearrange
that in the usual way,
except for keeping track of
these integrals, as follows.
So I imagine that there's
a z and a z inverse.
And the relation between z
and z inverse is as follows.
Let's just call
this double prime.
It's matrix multiplication
except in the function space,
right?
So this is like
a delta function.
So if you like,
you can just think
that there's more indices.
In some sense, what we have in
terms of the quark and gluon
operators mixing is a
matrix equation, right?
This is a vector.
This is a matrix.
This is a vector for
the indices i and j.
And you can think of this
integral here as just another--
it really looks, the
way I've drawn it,
like this is
contracted with that
and this is summing
over the indices.
And really, that's what it is.
So really, this idea that it's
just mixing of quantum numbers
is kind of a good way of
thinking about things.
And when you think
about formulas,
you know you're just
summing over these indices,
and the Kronecker delta
becomes a regular delta.
So in that sense, it's
not that hard to do this.
And so we get an anomalous
dimension equation
which, again, has
that kind of form
of just an integral for
the renormalized guy,
and it has mixing.
And this gamma ij, if
we go through the steps
and use this formula,
looks like this.
So I'm kind of
skipping steps, but I
hope that you can
kind of picture
where this result
will come from.
And it's actually not--
it's pretty easy to go from
that line with this formula
to this line.
This is one line, but I just
split it into two things
and defined this
quantity, gamma ij, which
is the anomalous dimension.
AUDIENCE: So this mu in QCD
[INAUDIBLE] factorization
scale?
IAIN STEWART:
Yeah, that's right.
OK, so at one loop,
things are simpler.
Because at one
loop, this thing, we
can just replace it by delta
ii prime, Kronecker delta
at one loop.
Because at one loop, we just
need the order alpha piece
from this guy, and then
we can set the tree level
for that guy.
So at one loop, which is
all we're going to do,
we get the simpler formula.
OK, so that's our
setup, and now we
want to calculate this
one-loop anomalous dimension
by calculating the 1
over epsilon alpha s term
and the zij.
Before I do that, is
there any questions?
All right, so tree level--
so think about there being an
external p for whatever state
I'm considering, and then
the operator is labeled by w.
And so we're summing over spin.
I've kind of somehow--
sometimes I've dropped that.
I said it last time.
And so we get some spinners,
and we got a delta function.
So what the delta
function in the operator
is it's delta function
of w minus this label,
momentum p bar.
And in something like this
where it's completely trivial
and there's just one state,
we just get the momentum
of that state, which is p.
This sum over spin
here is a p minus.
And so the result is
a delta function of 1
minus omega over p minus for
this tree-level matrix element.
One loop-- now we have
to think about how
we're going to regulate the IR.
And I'll do it with
an off-shellness.
So I'll introduce
a nonzero p class,
and that will be enough to
regulate IR divergences.
And we're really
after the UV one,
so we just want to
separate these guys out.
So there's some
different diagrams.
We insert our operator,
and we just attach gluons.
So one thing we can do
is just string a gluon
across kind of like a standard
vertex renormalization diagram.
So there's some loop momenta.
Let me label it
on the quark line.
And then the gluon here,
which is a collinear gluon,
has momentum p minus l.
And it's forward so
it's kind of set up.
There are some
numerator to deal with.
And I'm not going
to go through that,
but it simplifies to
something kind of simple.
After some [INAUDIBLE] algebra,
it simplifies down just
to an l perp squared.
For this diagram, there's
two l squared propagators,
and there's one l minus
p squared propagator.
And then there's
a delta function
from the insertion
of the operator,
but now the delta function
doesn't involve the [INAUDIBLE]
momentum as it did there.
It involves the loop
momentum, and that
was kind of the whole
point of this example.
So we have a delta function
of l minus minus w.
And then there's
some dimreg factors,
which we can be careful
about if we want.
So in MS bar, we'd have
some factor like that.
So this is some loop integral
that we just have to do,
and we can do it with kind
of standard techniques.
So in my, notes I wrote it
as a function of epsilon,
and then epsilon is just
regulating the ultraviolet,
and we expand in epsilon.
So let me just write down
the result after expanding.
So this is an
ultraviolet divergence,
and A here has the
infrared regulator--
p plus, p minus.
And it also has
a z and a 1 minus
z, which you can
group all together.
And z is just this ratio.
That thing is dependent on a
tree-level omega over p minus.
Now, when I'm doing
this calculation,
this is a small p, not
a big P, because I'm
using quark states,
not a proton state.
So really, if I wanted to
think about this as an f,
I should say it's an
f for the quark state.
But I think that you
can remember that.
But the renormalization
of the operator
doesn't depend on
the state, remember.
We always take the
simplest states possible
when we're doing
the renormalization
or doing matching.
And so we're free
to use quark states,
so that's what we're doing.
OK, that's one diagram.
Now there's another diagram.
I think that should be
B. Sometimes in my notes,
I'll call it 1, which
doesn't make any sense.
And we can contract the
gluon with the Wilson line.
So there's that graph, and
there's a symmetric friend.
And each of these actually
has two contractions
because there was two
Wilson lines in the way we
wrote our operators.
So our operator, as we
wrote, is like this.
And you can think--
so let's just
think of a contraction
with the quark.
You can think that there's
a contraction like that
and there's a contraction
like that of a gluon--
OK, I'm contracting
gluons with quarks.
But really, what
I mean is that I'm
contracting to the
Lagrangian, right,
that this quark
is evolving under.
So hopefully that's clear.
All right, so there's two
different ways in which--
when I work out the Feynman
rule for this thing where
I attach the gluon,
you can either
get the gluon from here
or the gluon from there.
That's all I'm saying.
But these actually
have different physical
interpretations because
this delta function
here, if you think
about what it's doing,
it's really-- in the original
diagram, it's like the cut.
So in the original diagrams
that we were drawing,
we would cut them because
we'd take the imaginary part.
And this delta function
is in the middle.
We have kind of a
parton on this side
and a squared
parton on that side.
This delta function is the cut.
So this contraction
here actually
corresponds to a virtual
graph, and this guy here
corresponds to real
emission because you're
doing a contraction
across the cut, right?
So one of these guys would
be a graph like this,
and the other one would
be a graph like that.
I can label them 1 and 2--
1, 2.
But we'll just keep them
and treat them all together.
These two graphs give
an overall factor of 2.
So that's simple.
There's some
spinner stuff, which
is even simpler in this
case, so I write it out.
There are some stuff
from the Wilson line.
And then there's
two propagators.
Let me not write all the i0's.
And then there's two
different delta functions.
So either we have the real
graph where the w is inside,
or we have the virtual
graph where the w--
sorry.
Either we have the
real graph where
the loop goes around
the delta function,
or we have the virtual graph
where this guy is overall
on that thing.
So in the overall one,
it's just a p minus minus w
like it was at tree level.
And in the real emission,
it's an l minus minus w.
And one's a w.
One's a w dagger.
So there's a relative sign.
So the sign is just
easier to understand
as w versus w dagger,
which has a relative sign.
OK, so if we just
followed our nose
with what the Feynman
rule for this thing is,
that's what we would get.
And this is, again, some
loop integral that we can do.
One way of writing the
result is as follows.
And there's one thing we have to
be careful about here which is
why I'm writing this all out.
So there's actually
a cancellation
between the virtual
and the real diagrams
of an infrared divergence, so I
want to be careful about that.
So that's why I'm writing this
guy out in epsilon dimensions
fully without expanding first.
OK, so this is the
real contribution,
and this is the virtual.
So in order to sort
of deal with this,
we have to make use of something
that's called the distribution
identity.
If you know what the result is
for the anomalous dimension,
you'll be aware of the
fact that it involves
something called a plus
function because splitting
functions for a
parton distribution
involves something
called a plus function.
So the way that we can deal
with that is as follows.
The way we can
deal with the fact
that actually the result's
going to be a distribution,
we have to be careful
because you see, z goes to 1
is being regulated by epsilon.
And so if we integrate
over z, for example,
it's epsilon that's
going to allow us
to integrate all the way to 1.
And we'd like to
encode that in some way
where we can expand in
epsilon because that's
what we need to do
in order to extract
the anomalous dimension.
And this formula is what
allows us to do that.
So I'll tell you
how to derive it
after I tell you what the l is.
So ln of anything is defined
to be a plus function
with a log to that power.
And the plus function
is defined so
that if you integrate
from 0 to 1, you get 0.
And if you integrate
with a test function,
which is the more general result
that you need to define it--
so you can define it by this
result with a test function.
And it just gives you
the normal function,
but the test function
with a subtraction that
makes the test function
more convergent
so that you can
integrate through 0.
OK, so that's the definition
of a plus function.
You could also define
it with a limit.
This will be sufficient.
OK, so these things are
like delta functions.
The way that you would
derive this formula
is you would say, well,
if z is away from 1,
then I can expand because
then there's no problem.
And if z is away
from 1, it turns out
that this plus function is
just the regular function.
It's only at 1 that something
special is happening.
And so the standard
expansion is what you'd
get if you took z away from 1.
And to see what's
happening at z equals 1,
you'd just integrate
both sides from 0 to 1,
and that's how you can
derive the coefficient
of the delta function.
All right, so if I plug this
formula in here for this thing,
then I actually get another
1 over epsilon in this guy.
There's a gamma of epsilon out
front, and that guy is good.
This is our UV divergence.
This is our 1 over epsilon UV.
But there's also a
gamma of minus epsilon
here, which is an IR divergence.
So even though I tried
to regulate all the IR
by off-shellness,
it didn't quite work
and there was one that
was regulated by dimreg.
And that one actually cancels
between these two pieces
once I use this identity
and take into account
that that's an IR divergence.
So there's a 1 over epsilon
IR times 1 over epsilon UV.
And that cancels between
the real and virtual graphs.
So this is like a
standard 1 over epsilon IR
canceling between real
and virtual graphs.
And since it's only
the 1 over epsilon UV
that we're interested in,
we're really only worried
about that part of it canceling.
There's a piece actually that--
anyway.
And then the 1 over
epsilon that's left
is the guy that
we're after in order
to get the anomalous dimension.
All right, so let me not--
so in my notes, I
write one more line
where I expand this guy out.
And I think just because of the
time, I'm going to skip that.
And I'll just write
the final result.
When we do the final
result, we also
have to include wave
function renormalization.
So you can think of this
graph as a wave function
renormalization term.
And it just involves
the delta function again
like the tree-level graph.
[INAUDIBLE] like that.
So in general, if I wanted to
do this calculation at one loop,
there's one more type of
diagram I should consider, OK?
And that's a graph where
I could have mixing.
This guy should be dashed since
we're in the effective theory.
So how does the
mixing graph work?
Well, there's a graph where
I have external gluons,
but I still am renormalizing
the same operator.
I've still inserted the
quark operator here,
but now we have
antiquarks in this theory.
We can draw a
triangle like that.
And this graph here would
give a mixing that involves--
that would give a mixing term
in the anomalous dimension
where you're mixing
gluons and quarks.
So this mix is what we
sort of called O glue.
Let me just say this, that
it mixes O glue with O quark.
And we could compute
this graph too,
but I'm going to neglect
it just for simplicity.
I just won't write it down.
One way of doing
that rigorously would
be to consider operators where
the flavors of these guys
are different, OK?
That's what would happen, for
example, if you were having
a w exchange or something.
So we could look at
nonflavored diagonal operators
with, like, a u
quark and a d quark.
And then you would not have
this mixing with O glue.
It's only if the
flavors of the quarks
are the same that you can
write down this diagram.
But just think about it as I'm
focusing on the quark piece,
and in general, there's
also a gluon piece.
So we have all our
one-loop graphs.
We know how to expand
them in epsilon.
And so we just proceed,
expand them in epsilon,
and add them up.
So you could think
that what we derive
by doing that is a distribution
for a quark inside a quark.
So here, I'm being--
this is the state
and this is what
type of operator.
And it's a function of some z.
And if I go up to one
loop, then the tree level
was just a delta function
of that fraction z.
And then at one loop, we
had all these other terms.
So if I collect all the pieces,
I had some delta functions.
The graph with the Wilson
lines actually gives me
one of these L0 functions.
And then the graph--
so there's wave
function normalization
plus some other terms that
involve delta function.
And then there's
some other pieces.
And then this is all
times 1 over epsilon.
And then there's other pieces.
But if we're interested in
ultraviolet renormalization,
we only care about
the 1 over epsilon.
And all those terms
can be written
in a kind of more
compact form, which
is the more standard form
for the anomalous dimension.
You can actually group them
all together into a single plus
function like this.
So just in terms
of distributions,
this distribution is equal
to the sum of these pieces.
You can see, as z goes
to 1, that there'd be a 2
here and a 2 here.
And this would be
1 over 1 minus z.
And as z goes to 1
here, that would be 1
and this would be
a 1 over 1 minus z.
So you see some pieces
of it matching up.
Basically, the way that you
would derive this is you'd
write 1 plus z squared
is a plus b, 1 minus z
plus c, 1 minus z squared.
You'd work out what
a, b, and c are,
just relating two polynomials.
And then this guy here, the
1 minus z in the numerator
cancels the one in
the denominator,
and it's not a plus
function anymore.
It's just a number.
And that's how you would
connect the two formulas.
All right, so we were
after determining the z.
The z has to cancel
this 1 over epsilon.
So let's go back to our
formula which connected
those, which was this.
Our general formula was
that the bare guy could
be written in terms of
split into UV pieces
and finite pieces in
the following ways,
is with this integral.
Now, this looks like it could
be an arbitrary function of xi
and xi prime, but our result
here was only a function of z,
which is actually a ratio.
And that's actually something
that we can argue in general,
that this thing here is
actually only a function
of one variable, not two.
So that follows from
two different things.
It follows from
RPI III invariance.
So remember that
RPI III invariance
said that you should have the
same number of n's and n bars.
And remember-- OK, so that's
one thing that you have to use.
That tells you that
you need to get ratios.
Well, the z's are
already ratios.
So you might say, well,
that should be fine.
The z's are already ratios
between the momentum
and the operator
and the momentum
and the state, the minus
momentum of the operator
over the minus momentum
of the state, right?
And this is a minus momentum.
That's a minus momentum.
So the z's are
RPI III invariant.
So that doesn't seem
like it would imply this.
But there's one
other thing you know,
and that is that it can't
depend on the state momentum.
I could have taken a proton.
I could have taken a quark.
And the result for
the renormalization
shouldn't depend on
what state I'm taking.
And this combination
where I have
d xi prime xi prime with a xi
over xi prime, the p minuses
cancel out.
So if I were to do the
whole thing with a proton
state rather than a
quark state, then I
should still get the
same anomalous dimension.
And in order for
that to be true,
it has to depend on the ratio.
And that ratio is then just
a ratio of the bare operator
and the renormalized operator.
It's like saying, if
you had O of omega,
there is a convolution
of z with an omega
over omega prime or
something, with O omega
prime renormalized.
And if I had done it in
an operator level and not
even written states,
then it would really just
be RPI III invariance, OK?
Because I wrote it
in terms of states,
there was this other
momentum available,
but I'm not allowed
to have that really
be playing a part
of the discussion.
So given that formula, then
I can expand to one loop.
So this guy I think of as
having a tree-level result.
This guy is a
matrix element that
has a tree-level and
one-loop result as well.
So if they're both tree
level, I get delta, 1 minus z.
And in some kind of obvious
notation, up to one-loop order,
I can write it out
formally like that.
And then I know what these
tree-level things are.
This guy's a delta
function, and this guy's
also a delta function.
So I can just do the integral.
And it really is pretty simple.
All the 1 over epsilon
terms are just z.
And what's left would be
associated to this guy
in perturbation theory.
But if we want to do
the renormalization,
we just need the z and
not worry about that.
So we read off
from over here what
z is because z is
just this right there.
So z-- OK, z is just this thing.
So when I put the
tree-level piece together
with the one-loop piece,
then this thing is just z.
And then I compute the
anomalous dimension
by taking mu d by d mu of it--
and that hits the alpha,
so that kills the epsilon
and gives me a factor
of 2 and a minus sign.
But the anomalous
dimension, gamma qq--
so there was a 1 over xi prime.
And then it was
minus mu d by d mu.
And if I plug it in the
formula that we have,
zqq of [? xi over ?]
[? xi ?] prime.
So there's an a minus here.
There's a minus there.
And the 2 epsilon cancels
this 2 and that epsilon.
And this 1 over xi
prime is the thing
that we needed to make
the measure RPI invariant.
So in this notation,
our original notation,
putting all the pieces
together and being careful
about beta functions, which I
was mostly suppressing, that's
the result. OK, so this
is the function of xi
over xi prime, which
I've just written as z.
And then there's
some beta functions
that are setting the
boundaries for the integral.
And that comes also
out of the calculation.
And that's the quark
one-loop splitting function.
So if we've done the gluon
from that other diagram,
that we've got the mixing term.
OK, so this is the one-loop
anomalous dimension
for the PDF, and
it's really just
doing operator renormalization,
calculating one-loop diagrams
in the effective theory.
Questions?
OK.
So one question
that you can ask,
which is an
interesting question,
is when we did this
result for the DIS,
we got this convolution
between the hard function
and the Parton
distribution function.
And you can ask,
why did that happen
and, in general, is there
a way of characterizing
when it could possibly happen?
Because if you think about
the answer that we got,
it was just Wilson
coefficient times operator.
And the really only
nontrivial thing about it
was that there was
this one momentum that
could kind of trade back
and forth between them.
There was an integral
in the answer.
And actually,
power counting even
constrains how those integrals
can, in general, show up.
So if you ask most generally
what could possibly happen--
and just thinking about
the power counting
for the degrees of
freedom actually
tells us what type of
integrals can show up
in factorization theorems.
This is constrained
by power counting.
I keep forgetting to say
that there's a makeup lecture
tomorrow.
I sent around an email,
but I should have--
tomorrow, this room at 10:00 AM.
And the lecture next week
is canceled on Tuesday.
That's why we have a
makeup lecture tomorrow.
OK, so in what way is it
constrained by power counting?
So if you think about the
degrees of freedom that we had,
say, for SCET I, then we had
hard, collinear, and soft--
so let's just take a
simple case with only one
type of collinear--
hard, collinear, and ultrasoft.
And the p mu of these guys in
terms of plus, minus, and perp
components--
I should be more
fancy about this.
[INAUDIBLE]
So if you think about just
power counting for the momentum,
it was as follows.
Factorization was separating
these different things
into different objects.
We had a Wilson
coefficient for the hard.
In the case we just did, we only
had a proton matrix element.
For the collinear, we
didn't have any ultrasofts.
If we put the ultrasofts in,
they would have all cancelled
away.
We wouldn't have seen any
ultrasofts showing up.
And that's because the
operator we were dealing with,
the Wilson lines would just have
cancelled completely out of it.
But actually, it turns out,
for deep inelastic scattering,
that you shouldn't even
include ultrasofts.
They're not a good degree
of freedom to include there.
So really, for the process
that we were talking about,
you really should
only take those two.
But anyway, more generally
in some other process,
you would have these
three different things.
And the way that
convolutions can show up
is simply who can trade
momentum with who.
So this is plus momenta, minus
momenta, and perp momentum.
And in order for
momentum to be exchanged,
they have to be
of the same size.
So these guys here are the same
size and they can be exchanged,
and that's exactly what showed
up in our DIS factorization
theorem.
The hard Wilson coefficients
exchanged minus momentum
with the collinear [INAUDIBLE]
because they are the same order
in the power counting.
In another case,
in a more general
or in some other
example, we might
find that there was
nontrivial ultrasoft stuff,
and then we could
get a convolution
in the plus momentum and
collinear and ultrasoft
because they're the same size.
And so that's a
pretty simple way
of thinking about why those
integrals can possibly show up.
It's just because the two
sectors can talk to each other
because they have momenta
that are the same size.
And then the rest is about
momentum conservation
because momentum conservation
places nontrivial constraints.
And we saw in the DIS
example that there
were two omegas to
start, but one of them
was projected to 0 because it
was a forward matrix element
and we only had one integral.
And that also has
analogs elsewhere.
If we do SCET II, which we
haven't talked about yet--
we did talk about what the
degrees of freedom were.
And again, if I try
to make it completely
generic for some examples
that we'll treat later,
then I can write
down something that's
a slightly extended version of
what we talked about so far.
So I can have Q, Q,
Q again for the hard.
And then I can
have my collinear,
which is Q lambda squared, Q, Q
lambda, and then soft, which is
Q lambda, Q lambda, Q lambda.
And it turns out that
sometimes, there's
also another mode which
we haven't talked about,
but I'll include it
for completeness, which
is kind of a
collinear mode that's
in between the
low-energy collinear
mode and the high-energy
collinear mode.
AUDIENCE: Do you mean the
square root of lambda?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, square
root of lambda, sorry.
Yeah, otherwise my
dimensions are wrong.
Yeah.
So again here, you can just--
I mean, the reason I was
extending this is just to,
again, argue that it's kind of
simple to see what can happen.
So in general, when you
think about convolutions
in the hard momentum,
it could be in this case
between these three modes.
There could be some integrals.
And then look where else
there can be something.
So this and this
are the same size.
And this and this
So in general, we
can have convolutions
in general between
all these things,
between the guys that
are the same size.
But that's the most complicated
thing that can happen.
It can't be more
complicated than that.
And you see that
in some examples,
you either have the purple
or the orange, but not both.
That's kind of
typical that you don't
get the most complicated thing.
So when you have results from
observables that tell you
how these things
couple together,
those are called
factorization theorems.
And in the effective
theory, because you sort of
define the modes, separated
them at the start,
you're kind of very quickly
getting to these factorization
theorems.
Let's see.
So we're going to deal with a
bunch of different examples.
And I decided that I'm going to
do it in the following order.
So we're going to
do the next exam--
so we're going to do
a bunch of examples
in order to see the range of
possibilities that can happen.
And so I'm going to stick
with SCET I for next lecture.
So the next example we'll do,
which I'll call example one,
is we'll do our
[? dijet ?] production.
So this is a SCET I situation.
And the difference
between the example--
so so far, what we
did is we did DIS.
DIS actually it was so
simple because it only
had two degrees of freedom
that you could kind of either
think of it as
SCET I or SCET II.
I mean, technically,
it's more like SCET II,
but it behaves like SCET I.
But there's no ultrasofts.
And remember, it's
ultrasofts and softs
that are making the
distinction between the two.
So if you just have
this mode and this mode,
it's not really any
difference between calling it
SCET I or SCET II.
So it's just SCET.
So e plus, e minus
to [? dijets ?]
will be an SCET I example
which has ultrasofts.
And actually, what
we'll find in this case
is that it will be the purple.
We'll get a purple convolution.
We'll see how that happens.
And we won't actually--
momentum conservation
will rule out the possibility
of the orange one.
So we'll see the
opposite situation
where it could be that we
have ultrasoft modes as well,
but then we only
get a convolution
with those ultrasoft in
the factorization theorem
and not with the [INAUDIBLE].
And then we'll turn to SCET II.
And I haven't totally decided
what processes I'll do,
but I think I'll do
the following ones.
So one thing that you can
do, which is pretty simple,
is to look at something called
the photon-pion form factor.
So real photon-to-pion
transition
through another
virtual photon, but you
can think of this happening
through a diagram like this
with two quarks,
one of them that's
off-shell and one of
them that's on-shell.
This is pi 0.
So this is a SCET II example.
But again, it's pretty simple
because it's just going
to involve one hadronic object.
And actually, it will
just, in this case,
have collinear modes.
We can set things up so
the pion is n-collinear,
and then we have hard modes.
So that's one example we'll do.
Another example we'll
do is B to D pi.
And here, the B
and the D are soft.
Remember, we talked about this
one, and the pion is collinear.
And then we have hard modes.
So this is kind of like,
in some sense, a DIS,
but it's an exclusive
process, not an inclusive one.
And so actually, all
the tools that we use,
which were kind of--
in DIS, it's the most inclusive
process you can think of.
It's deep inelastic scattering.
The I is for "inclusive."
Here, we're doing something
completely exclusive,
but we'll see that all the
things that we've been thinking
about, which is just
separation of collinear
modes and hard modes, will just
go through for that process
too.
So the effective
theory, the difference
is that in this case, you will
not be taking the amplitude
squared.
You won't be looking
at forward scattering.
The forward scattering was
what was making it inclusive.
We were summing over
all the final states.
Here, there's only
one final state.
So the difference between this
example and the one we just did
is that in this case, we'll
factor the amplitude, not
the squared amplitude.
But other than that, it'll look
very similar to the example
that we did for DIS.
B to D pi, then, is
an SCET II example
where we make things a little
more complicated because now we
have soft, collinear,
and hard modes.
And we'll see what
happens there.
And then I'll do some
more examples after that.
But let me say we'll
do some LHC examples.
And I think we'll
also do broadening,
which is another e plus,
e minus observable.
All right, so that's
where we're going,
and we'll start
going there next time
by talking about
[? dijets ?] and SCET I.